check out check out the story Adam I
don't think you know what this is I have
no idea
tick tocks skull breaker challenge lands
New Jersey boy 13 and hospital two
charged what let me explain to you let's
go break some oh gosh so I kind of go up
justjust well well let me first is I'm
like no look I'm an old man all right
I'm almost 34 my birthday's in a week we
actually our birthdays are basically
like a day apart yeah we actually are so
maybe I don't understand the kids these
days it's probably true and I can't
speak for them and I remember when I was
younger and they like would say things
about what we were doing they'd make
things up and we'd be like no one's
doing that you were insane you're making
that up
yeah so now we're here we heard about
Tide Pods like literally no one was
eating Tide Pods what there was one
story where a kid put in his mouth as a
joke and it broke because it would break
sit uh-huh and then it caused him to in
he rapidly inhaled a little bit and it
burned his lungs and his throat don't be
dumb and put a tie put in your mouth you
[ __ ] it's exact but he wasn't intending
to eat he was mm be funny and filler so
the scope breaker challenged the media
purports because it might be like a
fringe thing that only a couple people
have done and they're claiming is like
an epidemic so here's what happens you
get an unsuspecting rube and you tell
him to stand in the middle and say all
three of us are and take a picture we
all jump in the air and then you took
and then someone says gonna take a
picture and you go one two three and as
soon as they jump you kick their feet
out so they flip over and land on their
back that's so messed up and this kid
cracked his skull had a seizure and they
arrested the other kids so I've actually
got another story buzz cuz it's not the
first time it's happened they should be
arrested they shout they should so
here's a photo this kids like man dude
he had a seizure like what are those
your friends like it's it's terrible
kids there's John dude kids so here let
me let me let me qualify that statement
oh my gosh kids are ignorant there it is
kids are ignorant yes humans typically
have the same capability to learn and to
understand and know things yeah but
there's so much they don't know and so
they're like you know the knockout game
no but it's just like this
not really the knockout game is where
you run up to someone and knock them out
like a random stranger and people were
doing this that will run at full speed
and just crack someone in the skull
person old people let me tell you man
terrible let me tell you a warning let
me tell you all story there's something
I learned when I was a little kid there
was a guy my mom had worked with and
apparently there was they were at a
business gathering for her company there
was a guy and his wife and this other
guy who was like the suave you know you
know Rico suave kind of like eight
what's up was hitting on the wife and so
the husband got angry the Rico swung on
to a fight the suave guy punched him in
the face he fell back hit his head and
died and guess who got charged with
murder and went to prison the guy who
was like I just threw punch I didn't
know it doesn't matter dude people don't
realize because they think they can
watch a movie like knock someone out you
could punch someone in the forehead and
they could die you're right you could
kick someone and they can hit their head
and die you didn't wanna play those
games I will also add humans are more
resilient than people give him credit
for true like they think you know people
are delicate will fall over and die nah
you'll be okay sometimes but there are
those people out there that will crack
this code and have a seizure little
cannot trust anyone checks out years and
years and years let's read this they say
to New Jersey students face criminal
charges after their classmate was
seriously injured during a school break
or challenge a dangerous game that
involves a person being tricked into
jumping in the air as someone else kicks
their feet from under them the challenge
has been recorded on video and shared on
social media platforms just tik-tok
Stacey Stacey Schenker of Cherry Hill
whoa this is like close to us you know
well that's really close that's like
only that's ridiculously close yeah said
she and her husband had never heard of
the game until it sent their
thirteen-year-old son to the hospital in
January with a major concussion she told
NBC in a phone interview Tuesday that
she received a call from her son's
middle school in Cherry Hill on January
24th informing her the 7th grader had
been injured at the time she arrived at
the school roughly 20 mins later
Schenker said her son was non-responsive
and an ambulance had been called first
responders told her the boy had suffered
a seizure
she said that kid's gonna have permanent
brain damage most likely yeah that
people don't get it man
I've growing up skateboarding a lot of
people you know they'll talk to you by
the importance of helmets and so just
don't want to do it and there are
certain circumstances where no matter
how good you think you are you wear
helmet like vert skating around stuff
exactly you certainly do a lot of Street
skating you don't
it'sit'sit's low to the ground you don't
want any not getting that whiplash
bottoms there's some tricks though that
it's people people hit their heads but
it's an issue of altering your center of
gravity and you know it's I don't think
it's that big of a deal but I think but
there's always a chance and as you can
tell someone and they can die I didn't
fall off your skateboard and also die in
the same sense yeah don't say it like
that it's no but here's the thing
the the thing about skateboarding is
that you earn your way to that level
that's alright don't just jump on a
board and try jumping off a building
okay you got a point yeah you might want
to put on people do more easy stuff no
are there great experts you know I mean
well what's up with these kids nowadays
that think that they can just go that
long that then and also that this kind
of stuff is funny hurting people you
know come on well no no no like
ridiculousness rob dyrdek show yeah like
half of the show I'm like I don't want
to see this yeah this isn't funny to me
this is I feel bad for that person they
are seriously hurt didn't you ever watch
jackass or CKY yeah yes Margera that's
them doing it to themselves that's
different right right right all of that
when it's an accident or someone that
doesn't know that they're involved
that's not funny to me
that gingers me and he sent exactly yeah
the jackass all had consent it was them
when they were all running and jumping
off buildings and jumping and whatever
they were doing when they would get a
pie in the face it was because they knew
the rules of the game they played with
each other exactly and they did know to
expect yeah they didn't know what to
expect but they always expected
something to happen right yeah this is
different always happen some dumb kid
and they were like dude we're gonna
knock come on oh this is gonna be so
funny we're gonna get so many likes yeah
that's all it was that's what we're
gonna get internet-famous check us out
well actually so this is a post from
from the New York Post skull breaker
challenge going viral and tick tock
could be fatal doctors warned I want to
come back to this cuz one I make a point
where they talk about the kids who are
charged I want to get what did they say
what they were charged they got third
degree something or other let me type it
in there we go the to Cherry Hills
students accused of injuring chancres
son have been charged with third degree
aggravated assault and third degree
endangering an injured victim the Camden
County Prosecutor's Office told NBC News
on Tuesday so here's the thing good but
what really
yes because it sets a precedent for the
other people that do this kind of stuff
I don't I don't believe in the setting
an example on someone who is dumb like
is it really gonna help these kids or
help anyone else because you set an
example I don't know the solution is man
I don't know what do you just let them
let him go and be like don't do it again
um maybe do what what's our goal here I
mean I'm not saying that they need to be
that it needs to stick and be on the
permanent record forever but that risen
dude well I mean aggravated assault of
those other felony their 12 year old 13
year olds yeah they're not gonna go to
prison well they go to juvie I guess it
depends on what they what they're gonna
get
they're not gonna go to juvie this
sounds like it's near us it's probably
aggravated school of white people
aggravated assault is pretty shots of
privilege is gonna shine through here
annoyingly right right right that I
agree with that they're not gonna
they're not gonna go to prison they're
gonna get it's gonna get reduced to
probation and they're gonna have to do
like a hundred and fifty hours of
community service but I don't think
that's gonna teach them anything and I
don't think it's gonna teach anyone else
anything so I I look I don't why are you
kids so crazy I don't understand I know
that's not our audience but man I don't
get this at all
hurting Leigh so what he's not funny
what do you thinks gonna happen when
someone jumps in the air and you make
them fall into their neck yeah okay and
then they get paralyzed
you know they break their their spine
like that look at this this is not the
first night that that story wasn't the
first time and it happened like this
this is uh I mean this this is a talking
about the fatality potential of the
skull breaker challenge but you can see
like they're all laughing and they're
dudes Isis Oh anything in pain yeah I
would not I would never be friends with
someone who did that to me I'd be like
oh you're cut off from my life I will
never speak to you again that's messed
up you know if you hurt me physically no
no no no I cut you off I think this is a
similar phenomenon to what's driving
people insane on social media making
them like you know ultra whoa social
justice lunatics okay it's the same as
this
it's one-upsmanship yeah okay so like a
kid flicks someone here in films that
and laughs and everyone laughs and the
next person smacks him in the face the
next you know kid kicks him in the balls
and then they're not gonna hit some over
a head with a chair
yep and it just keeps escalating now
obviously that's it like you know a bit
of an exaggeration but these kids
they're you know what man
it's because they see it on social media
and they're like wow that's really funny
I want to do that I want to hurt someone
because I want to get those clicks so
I've got I've actually got another story
that I was I was thinking of saving for
later but I think it actually goes in
line with why these kids are doing these
things there's a dude I got I don't know
exactly how much of this we can show
without getting in trouble
Joker impersonator arrested after a
Facebook live broadcast here's a guy who
thought it would be funny because once
again it's an escalation of what people
are doing on social media right he
dresses up like the Joker and walked
around apparently saying who's gonna
start killing people and didn't anyone
arrested for it and he was streaming it
live dude this is what people are doing
now that nowadays Butler look at the
smile on his face that looks to me like
he's thinking I'm I'm gonna be seen on
yup the Internet yep I'm gonna be known
yep that's what that look is too likes
so you remember your numbers the
Columbine yeah attack and they were
motivated very much by that same fame
we're gonna be on the news they're going
to talk about us so they did they say
that in his journal
well here's for the record I don't know
your name and I never want to write yeah
but I don't know how you it's not even
about that we've created a machine that
churns this out it's got work even if it
even if it goes only goes to a hundred
people yeah I went to VidCon which is
the like the big video conference I
haven't been there in a couple years but
I remember hearing little kids talking
as I was walking into the building yeah
and one kid goes how many subscribers do
you have I have 87 and the kid goes 103
you have 103 subscribers and that's how
they view it and I thought that's that's
kind of cool to an extent like these
kids are learning how to be their own
individual personality which is good for
individualism and entrepreneurship and
stuff like that but it only applies to
this online bubble world it's at the
time is this long it's a point system of
attention right and so people are
desperate for this well there's no
getting attention from their families
anymore it's all on
everything what do you thinks gonna
happen to these people when they grow up
and they're desperate to maintain those
numbers so like there's a phenomenon on
YouTube where youtubers get depressed
when their views go down like this
literally excuse me this literally
happens where someone will get like a
million views on a video and then the
next day we'll get 700,000 and you'll
see them go nuts about it they'll be
like what's going on
YouTube's broken it's like mmm sometimes
you get less views sometimes your videos
bad sometimes people are watching the
Super Bowl and they're not watching your
videos right what happens a lot and a
lot of youtubers have talked about it
where they're like I started getting
depressed when I wasn't getting enough
views because grow infinite growth is
impossible there's a market cap for what
you produce right so what happens to
these little kids they grow up they're
doing these stupid things like scroll
breaker getting all these likes but
there's a cap to it man yeah you're not
gonna get you can't get more likes than
there are people so eventually you're a
30 year old guy being like I only got 58
million oh and you're like shaking like
what's wrong why aren't I getting enough
I need more attention and so they're
gonna start snapping going nuts one of
the things I think about with like why
child actors and actresses go crazy all
the time it's kind of like this if
you're a little kid and everyone tells
you the best everyone tells you you're
great oh you're so awesome do this now
do this you've got all this attention
you're on stage and everyone loves you
you grow up thinking that's the normal
level of love now when you're older and
things calm down because you're not the
cue you know famous kid anymore now
you're feeling like even though you are
well known you're not getting that same
level attention now it feels like you're
doing wrong and you're probably getting
and it probably are getting depressed
yeah
very much so like what happens these
people on social media we're gonna build
a generation of addicted kids and
they're gonna start doing crazy mother
effin stuff well I mean you know this
goal breaker challenge it's getting
there
it's this is getting to that crazy point
where they could want someone's gonna
get killed from this all bro it's gonna
get worse I mean he cracked his skull
open already yeah and went has permanent
brain damage yeah exactly it's like
hello kids
you're hurting each other I buddy
parents you know I think man I think
too many parents are like everything
there's there's too much that's to blame
there's so money chance
ya know that the kids are yelling in my
ears give them a screen mm-hmm get them
out of my hair
yep absolutely abdication of
responsibility that's quite an I can't
deny that you're absolutely right I
think that's probably it and I I mean
I'm looking at these two kids they look
entitled they look they think they can
do whatever they want to do can you hop
pop this up so people know what I'm
looking at here look at it look at these
two kids you can't you can see it on the
guy on the right is like yeah I just did
that I don't care at all they're they're
both laughing they think it's hilarious
it's like you guys have no idea that
when you guys are in 20 years you're
gonna be nobody's doing nothing it's not
itching to get that that fame that they
now have we have it now look we're
talking about them that's them on the
screen and they're probably happy they
here's nobody man it's about honor they
my mother and thy father mm-hmm it's
about understanding limits boundaries
parents were supposed to set those
things they're supposed to tell you what
you can and can't do to keep you safe
you know give you help give you a happy
healthy life people they're not doing it
it's like oh no the school will do that
right the school will teach that yeah
now go friends that are teachers and
they're like I hate every single student
that has the parents that are like that
because they definitely know they can
tell you need even if there's like a
solid family that like the kids like hey
that kids all right oh look his mom and
dad just dropped him off this kid is a
total jerk that you know if I'd impose
here's what I would do many different if
I if I was a teacher and I dream and I'd
if I was teacher night his students who
was like that you know parents weren't
disciplining him and stuff and he was
acting up I'd be like bro in my class
you can literally do whatever you want
like don't even worry about it man you
want to come any more airplanes like do
it to it man let me know if you need
anything do not care I am NOT gonna be
that person in your life who's supposed
to come in like your parents want me to
do anything
nah man just don't just don't step on my
feet I won't step on yours how does that
sound
and the kids gonna be like I'm do what I
want and be like yeah good not my
responsibility
yeah like but but it's but it's also
know if you did that though I bet the
kid would be like Oh
I feel like I should try a little bit in
this class it's not it's not about that
that's it that's the vibe I'm getting
it's about telling the kids straight up
mm-hmm like I'm not gonna do not you
know I'm not gonna war with you yeah you
know I'm not here I'm not I'm not here
to go to war with you I'm here to teach
the people that want to learn yep
basically yeah I think I'd be a good
teacher because I'd be doing so it would
be crazy fun we'd like you know spray
liquid nitrogen on things and like
shatter them and stuff because like
weird stuff like this your class we
would learn the weirdest things I would
do tons of crazy stuff too I like order
pizza I would go to your class I'd be
like today's lesson is pepperoni you
know what
Congrats that's I feel like I'm in your
class every day I come down here and I'm
like so what's on the news inform me of
things yes our pool I do crazy stuff I'd
be like what you guys want to do it's
true here are the things we're supposed
to do but let's try and figure out cuz
as long as we're all getting getting the
grades and like everyone's cool we can
make this you know more relaxing I think
the problem with school is the parents
want to pass off the kids and the
teachers don't want to be involved at
all instead of just being like digit
hang out with kids I don't know that
sounds kind of fun
it is like teaching them how to skate
and stuff you Jim I play music teaching
skateboarding it's easy I understand is
boring well nobody it was in my class
that didn't want to learn skateboarding
well there was there was actually one
kid who looked at me and said I'm I
don't want to be here and I was like wow
this is parent I'm in an interesting
situation because I was like what do you
want to do and they were like I want to
play guitar and I'm like oh man I wish I
had my guitar right yeah that's like I
don't just force you to like learn
skating but what did his parents want
him to or some his parents are like
here's a board yo you should be a skater
because skaters are cool and they're
cool and they make money and he's like I
don't want to do this it's like why man
tell that to your parents yeah but he
didn't tell it to his parents I was like
dude you gotta tell your parents
well sweetness to an extent I'll tell
you what to an extent parents making
their kids rude or play sports and do
music and stuff you know they don't want
to is still a really good thing true
I'll tell you what man you got a trial
the different things I get that is you
don't want to do something now it's like
skateboarding you can get hurt
like I can understand you can get hurt
but yo you it can
teach you things I know your your whole
listen I know a lot of clinical versus
inherence made them to do things like
play guitar play violin yeah and now
they're in the 30s they're like men I'm
so glad my parents did that okay like I
know people who learn Spanish it sure
works and they're like man I'm so glad
my parents made me learn Spanish but
were those like really solid families I
wouldn't call him really solid
oh well regular not really salad but
together normal families you'd say not
the way you'd explain well listen this
get this wasn't this kid was not he had
rich he was it's from right southeast
Manhattan you know they lived in a
penthouse he was like he could do he did
everything he had all the different
classes of every single different thing
and they're like nope you got to do
skateboarding too when he was already I
think it's a good thing yeah because you
got look well he was miserable and it
was really tough to teach someone who
didn't want of course of course I think
the challenge is I I wouldn't I would
not wish growing up a rich on anyone
that would not do it okay because the
you know with with all due respect to
the people I know there are a lot of
people I know who grew up rich who I
would consider to be developmentally
malformed okay in like they don't
understand simple concepts like like
I'll give an example asking someone if
they want to spend a weekend in
Switzerland with you is like so horribly
out of touch yeah I agree and then
asking your male clerk why they can't
afford to fly to Switzerland I'm like
dude do you have no idea how the world
works when you grow up in these weird
isolated world you know yeah
the average person's like to go to
Switzerland you gotta save three grand
lands no no no and then you break your
foot you go to the hospital you're like
so much for Switzerland yeah exactly but
I know I know people and I'm trying to
be mean who literally I was like you
know it was like a long long time ago
who've been like hey you want to come to
Europe with us and I was like you're we
talking about yeah dude are you kidding
and they were like oh oh I mean you're a
simpleton oh no they were my friends
they were just like oh like we're gonna
we're gonna go to Switzerland and I was
like dude like you know I'm like paying
200 bucks a month swim in a couch right
waiting for this you want to pay for and
but there but it's like when you win
when
when you grow up without having to work
hard yeah that's why I'm like maybe
thank you start kicking out your friends
thinking it's funny well they know that
right this is right this is when parents
don't teach kids yeah what the limits
are there's a separation and it's crazy
like I I knew a few rich families that I
know like the people my age now they had
nannies that raised them oh I got a
poison when I want you you want to know
who did drugs well which which class of
people did drugs when I was growing up
the rich people all of them all of them
every four people and the rich people
like well when I went to New York it was
like I never really saw it until I got
into the clubs and saw the VIP booth and
got into the VIP booth just by knowing
people and then boom I finally saw I
will mention this though like in Chicago
when I was growing up those notorious
that it was the suburb kids who always
had the craziest drugs and the poor kids
had kingcobra forties for like a buck
from the liquor store yeah so yeah
everybody was doing something nuts but
the suburb kids were the ones who are
like throwing crazy parties cuz they had
the money to do their parents would be
like here's your allowance here's money
or whatever there and we're gonna be
gone for the for the weekend long
weekend and now we're these kids my
generation where are they socialists
like asking the government to pay for
everything like why why can't you pay
for this for me it's like well do you
have to work for things no I don't you
do well why don't you just go to jail
right that is where they'll take care of
everything I learned earlier thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you